[Applaudissements]
faites de boris a commencé à travailler
immédiatement après la libération de
paris s'est créé le saint germain qui va
devenir pendant 40 ans à peu près le
capital de la culture française
qu'est-ce que quelques skis c'est toi
c'est pas mon truc je ne permettrai soit
pierre qui s'est dit qu'avec des
grimaces bon est ce qui fait dire et le
redire tout moi j'étais au tabou le jour
où boris a chanté pour la première fois
il part étudier à changer pour le vent
bien paul déserteurs merde c'est au
musée
[Rires]
assouvir et regardez là j'ai encore du
temps 2001 maire émouvant mais chez
pierrot noir quasiment et je pleure
téléspectateurs sachez que pierre et moi
on se connaît très très bien
on a travaillé plusieurs années ensemble
donc vraiment on voit la ronde et on est
assez proches au pire on a eu des fous
rires en soir oui je me sens assez bien
on a pleuré de rire je suis vraiment
sous sûr que pierre et moi on a pleuré
de rire avec benhaim et à chaque fois je
repense à tous les formats condamne la
rade d'hyères je suis je suis
extrêmement content vous soyez avec nous
et aussi le nouvel add malak des
histoires extraordinaires
je vais vous